tutti ragazzi a mente questo video sono
fa vigili oggi siamo tornati sul milioni
episodio 2
buona visione [ __ ] a ok basta
staccare la corrente basta chi me lo fa
fare giocasta roba chi la curia di un
uomo la goduria largo madonna quanto
godo che casino era non ha bisogno
ma perché c'è gente che gira e sto cazzo
di posto come affetta da arrivare qua
dai mi chiamò lì ci sono arrivati lì io
no [ __ ] marca ci vuole l'altra
tessera quanta fox 37 dai dai dai dai
che so tutto come ho fatto a non vederlo
prima aperto la cassaforte dentro c'è la
chiave del secondo piano o meno al 3 2 1
o mostro ah no
che strano perché adesso arriva giocato
meno e la tirano da riconoscere il punto
esatto il guerin i mostri il in crema
incredibile nel scioccato sa cosa avete
in chiave al secondo piano ha giocato la
porta bene
c'è uno stetoscopio qui ma qualcosa è
uscito dalla bottiglia non la tocca a
mani nude
se guardo televisore di spunta samara di
the ring me ne vado
bene ma se non funzionano vorrei tanto
vedere che le immagini stanno
trasmettendo sia di monito perché non
capisco non ha senso che lampeggiano se
la scatola degli attrezzi c'era piccola
palla di vetro
vi chiedo perché cosa dovrebbe essere
utilizzata trentina che cazzo armato a
salutarmi giusto dopo cosa perfetto va
bene [ __ ] la palla di vetro tegra
è cascato quadro una leva ma manca la
leva arriverà l'ora
porca [ __ ] però mi ha fatto un po di
cacciatori anche tu no no no no no no
non sa centrale gli armadi ce l'ho fatta
[Applauso]
questo perché io parlo devo parlare però
beh allora tua sorella morta fammi
capire dove andare per non farmi beccare
ma magari non vado giù direttamente
quando tipo qualche star calmi però andò
testare cala di tutti cos'è
ma gesù ma va beh non fanno niente
lasciamo pergola come vinco subito e
anche lui non ho parole
sono riuscito la rete come io che sono
impedite in ste cose sono riuscito ma
veramente hai ottenuto piede di porco
tosto casinò chrome piedi di porco poi
vabbè a mia zia posso dartelo sui denti
cosa faccio male poi ci passo io per una
sedia da ma che problemi hai zio
[ __ ] che cosa buttare che cade
assurda e vengono di puoi uscire anche
la sosta però è riuscito la ii dan a
casa o dio bambino di otto stato fatto
da cassa dell'ente che ciò che dipenda
ma io la trovo che kakà
oddio perché questo scappato il ci credo
ma chrome e dai per il prof non
importare la famiglia la squadra ha
mostrato dice la chiave di una mostra di
sulla scatola c'era mikki chiave di
ceramica scusatemi cosa dovrebbe essere
a bari da yo ma se il testardo e proprio
la [ __ ] vacca e non so cosa c'é qua
sotto leva da caso a caso avrete infatti
pare quella era quella di prima visione
ti prego che insieme a questo ma che si
apre questa sera festa aiuto che culo
non c'era mi seguiva più perfetto non ci
fa ma che culo lancia la cassaforte
attraverso la stanza vai da usare per il
borgo erano preso per cosa
melo lecco tipo miley cyrus col martello
non si apre la cassaforte dopo sapere
solo con un attrezzo particolare o il
piede di porco no non è quello e allora
a [ __ ]
cos'è sta roba
posso cercare nella credenza sotto
lavandino sì c'è qualcosa qua sotto ma
non posso raggiungerla tiri in porta ma
serve a qualcosa sul piede di porco no
ryan non la fermezza che cazzo fatto
grazie a dio sei tu dove consorella
chiediamo di subito il suo sorelle
dovete essere la lei si è persa non so
dove andrà tutto bene proviamo tua
sorella e andiamoci ok ok il venuto rida
ragazzi non è che lui ti poco strisciare
sotto il lavandino anzi coralmente siena
prova
eccolo là c'è una chiave da giova ai
premi a previa per favore provaci come
non è che sia tanto più piccole gothic
va bene grazie zio chiave blu è nato è
stronzo prima e cibo ma non esci più sta
attento prova non fare troppo rumore va
bene perché ci stiamo nascondendo da
qualcuno si già nascondendola che si ok
è come un gioco
hayden sic nascondino si e ti conosco
dire vabbè ma perché in questo momento
ci siamo separati nelle altre stanze no
non ho capito
ryan 6 a quella parte della stanza ok ok
non promette per niente bene
perché non penso sia dalla partita di
strano o merda merda
c'è qualcosa qui ryan vai a nasconderti
per me è ok ci giochiamo a nascondino io
conto fino a 30 a 30 29
perché riuscisse meno ma marca bak ha
trovato un guanto in lattice adesso
possono maneggiare quella sostanza
schifosissima ma anche che si erano
spostate le scatole tutto un tratto come
mai sto gioco deve essere quindi strano
non può essere normale non possono
succedere cose normali 3f chi ok posso
dare fino al terzo piano possa andare
un'ora di gioco per arrivare fin qua
un'ora di gioco
daje
il chievo è chiuso qualche uso bene ma è
la partenza è ottima
c'è un'altra porta al 3 porte mica tutto
allegro sto posto comunque meraviglio
chiave giovane
la chiave giovine cosa apro la chiave
già lo sapevo nello sfondare la porta ma
che cosa è uscito lui a caso la parte
chiusa merda apriranno a chiave giovane
chiara giovane non ci credo mai però c'è
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai zio
desio desio forza se io allora ragano
una dilettante difficile aiuta aia ce
l'ho fatta ringraziando a cristo
anzi a parte proprio figlio e vabbè
questa roba qua sarebbe partecipare ma
voi siete scemi a gesù mai farmi leggere
dice che c'è qualcosa a destra mano
capita di strà dove des tra cui gesù
gesù gesù aiutami ti prego che è sì ma
poiché che cazzo ci fai qui e aspetta
che cosa c'è nell'altra stanza che esse
è intrappolato dietro una gabbia l'ho
chiuso lì come hai fatto
è mia mi ha seguito e c'era una chiave
nel pavimento e posso da possa andare a
dare un'occhiata
no per favore non lo farei lo sci dammi
10 secondi è una donna quanto veloce ha
fatto io ha fatto e fa tutto lui non
vorranno vuoi trovare ryan prima che lo
faccia qualcun altro certo
rimane lì a fianco va bene va bene
diamo perfetto io non ho assolutamente
visto cosa c'è ma anche perché non mi
aveva fatto vedere è entrato uscito
subito perché mi hai chiuso un mostro
dentro la roba brava zia chiave vecchio
ottenuta o prima era la chiave giovane
adesso chiaramente va bene
ho ringraziato gesù permesso ho bisogno
di trovare le persone io trovato sopra
si infiamma dietro le scapole aiuto
quando sei senza speranza circa un dato
la cosa più bella che puoi fare è
circondarti va bene aiuto che stai perle
di saggezza non servono per scappare
degli altri
vai asta [ __ ] che rimane lio ferma
pure cioè anche dice ma voi avete capito
di che cosa voleva dire il messaggio una
cosa che puoi fare è circondarti ok
dovrei aver chiuso tutto in teoria non
dovrebbe mancare niente raduno vai
togliti la ventola
quindi ragazzi questo era il secondo
episodio di mira oni il prossimo solo
all'ultimo quindi sarà il finale perché
dura poco ni raoni però è meglio perché
dopo un po diventa uno stress cercare
tutte ste minchia di chiavi
va beh spero vi sia piaciuto al costo il
momento vi piace anche al comitato
descrizione del sito e ci vediamo a
seguito da ragazzi
[Musica]